le point central de votre livre c'est
les téléphones seraient dangereux pour
notre santé c'est ce car c'est ça qui
m'intéresse aux téléspectateurs un ring
aujourd'hui hausse des cancers du
cerveau notamment est-ce qu'on s'a on
l'a vraiment vu parce que c'est vraiment
la question que se posent nos
téléspectateurs et qu'on retrouve dans
le livre un hausse des cancers alors
clairement aujourd'hui quand quand on
parle de ça la la la fox qu'il passe
dans tous les journaux c'est de dire il
n'y a pas d'augmentation des cancers
d'ailleurs je regrettais d'ailleurs que
le docteur michel cymes qu'elle a des
médecins les plus écoutées des français
sur rtl disait exactement sa deuxième
rang qu'il n'y a pas de quoi faire et
bien c'est parfaitement faux peut savoir
en iran la période de détente dernière
et là on sait ce que c'est c'est santé
public français à notre agence sanitaire
qui dans les statistiques
fin 2010 elle a montré qu'il y avait une
multiplication par quatre et plus par
des cancers les plus graves
c'est à dire les glioblastomes et quand
on parle d'un glioblastome pas là pour
ceux qui ne savent pas la durée de vie
ces quelques mois et la mortalité s'est
quasiment et ça multiplie par quatre et
donc si vous voulez pour vous donner des
chiffres parce qu'on parle beaucoup de
chiffres en ce moment ça représente 50
mille morts rien qu'en france sur les
vingt dernières années et je ne parle
que des cancers les plus graves
je ne parle pas des gliomes je ne parle
pas des neurinomes de l'acoustique y est
c'est fait alors que ça vous allez voir
il ya d'autres problèmes avec le
téléphone aux siens on va regarder juste
qu'on a on va passer à la dernière
partie de touche pas au poste et on va
regarder le témoignage de gira regard
des dernières parties
on a le témoignage de gérard un homme
victime d'un cancer du cerveau
suite à l'utilisation régulière d'un
téléphone portable à son travail
alors ça regardez vraiment ce témoignage
parce que à chaque fois une dernière
docteur on sait pas on se dit est ce
qu'il aurait eu son compte son cancer du
cerveau sans le téléphone ou pas c'est
un petit peu sur ça que joue aussi
certaines personnes et 10 voilà toutes
les façons c'est pas dû au téléphone il
aurait eu quoi qu'il arrive on va voir
le témoignage
après quand girard du shass thoniers
nous reçoit il lutte contre son cancer
depuis plus d'un an
retraités d'atos cet ingénieur
informatique a passé plus de trente ans
dans l'entreprise
je faisais du support aux clients donc
pour ça ça se faisait par téléphone le
téléphone filaire
non non non un smartphone le téléphone
vous l'aviez collé à l'oreille je
l'avais collé à l'oreille oui alors
c'est vrai que ça chauffait ça chauffait
un peu c'est normal nous avons réussi à
identifier les locaux dans lesquels
gérard du shass tony a travaillé juste
en face de l'antenne relais
voilà alors vous dites donc hausse des
cancers se ce monsieur c'est sûr que
c'est à cause de ça mais ce qu'il faut
c'est entendre ce que dit santé publique
france parce que là bon il ya ces
témoignages et d'ailleurs dans
l'excellent documentaire qui est en
replay sur france 2 2 complément
d'enquêté vraiment il faut regarder ce
documentaire la santé publique france 10
dans les dents les conclusions
finalement qu' il y a un lien possible
avec la cancérogénicité des ondes de
téléphones portables et c'est pas ma
recaser qui le dit risque c'est santé
les souliers pour comprendre il paraît
qu'il ya des problèmes cardiaques aussi
bon alors là en l'occurrence on a eu et
dans l'actualité récente
la question des gens qui sont cardiaque
outils pour bp specter et alors là c'est
ça s'est focalisée sur l'iphone 12 et
d'apple et tout d'un coup apple du fer
entre guillemets amérique ou pas en
expliquant qu' il
il pouvait y avoir un problème de
dysfonctionnement du pacemaker vous
imaginez bien que quand j'ai appelé ce
week-end à un dysfonctionnement c'est
grave
et juste pour préciser
il y a à peu près 350 mille français qui
on a minima des pacemakers donc ce sujet
là aujourd'hui il devrait être dans la
formation au grand public on devrait
être dur est passé et aux informations
télévisées
ça ne l'est pas alors et l'électro
hypersensibilité c'est quoi l'électro et
persiste alors ça c'est aussi une des
conséquences de la surexposition aux
autres c'est à dire que vous avez alors
selon là encore les chiffres de notre
agence sanitaire hans hess agents
sanitaires et environnementales sont pas
les chiffres de marc hardy mais il ya un
rapport qui a été fait en 2018 et qui
monte qui a plus de trois millions trois
millions de personnes concernées par
exposé sensibilité et quand je dis le 3
millions c'est pas des doux dingues ça
concerne maintenant tous les genres et
société on en connaît tous autour de
nous ce soit d'ailleurs des journalistes
médias tels des présentateurs des
avocats des médecins des infirmiers
chauffeur de bus à tout le monde et en
gros vous avez des gens qui ont à voir
des signes signaux faibles comme des
motets des acouphènes des vertiges la
des rougeurs et puis la pire des
situations c'est à dire des gens qui
sont totalement désociabilisés parce
qu'ils ne peuvent plus vivre sans là où
il ya des ombres à la d'accord il ya un
autre truc qui serait néfaste et là je
dis je croyais pas moi je pensais que
c'était bien c'est les écouteurs alors
peut-être peut-être avant de parler des
écouteurs dire un mot sur les questions
sanitaires liés à la fertilité
parce que on téléphone portable je
n'aurais pas mais voilà ne surtout le
premier message
on va passer que vous allez rouler hier
lâche michel rollier régulièrement
ne mettez plus votre téléphone dans la
poche que j'ai vu la durée du tournage
devant la dix derrière
en gros arrêts en gros il faut
complètement arrêté de mettre le
téléphone au contact du corps et au
contact de l'oreille bon et ça
aujourd'hui il ya encore une étude
indienne qui est sorti cette semaine
elle qui faisait une analyse des études
et qui montre qu'il y a un problème
d'infertilité masculine avec le problème
l'arrêt mort à cause du téléphone à
cause des téléphones portables donc
c'est aussi ce sujet là bah oui parce
qu'il ya des études on n'en parle pas
mais c'est parce qu'on n'en parle pas
que ça n'existe pas bien sûr